what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe lately of course
everybody has been talking about wanda
vision the first three episodes are out
and we have
kind of no idea what exactly is going on
they're sword agents within this reality
we see things about hydra we believe
mephisto and grim reaper are really the
ones pulling the strings in this reality
and we know that this will eventually
connect to doctor strange and the
multiverse of
madness but when will this all start to
make sense yesterday i shared a few
things that elizabeth olsen and paul
bettany said
about episode 4 but now the head writer
and executive producer jack schaefer has
opened up about episode 4 as well
and now i can gladly tell you all that
we are getting
at least some answers in one division
episode four
this friday as i just mentioned
executive producer and head writer jack
schaefer was interviewed by heroic
hollywood and she was also interviewed
by the rap in which she had some
interesting things to
say in both of these interviews while
speaking with heroa collywood they said
that during the first three episodes you
barely understand what exactly is
happening to wanda but you definitely
have an idea that something is terribly
wrong
and they asked when exactly are we going
to be getting some answers and which
jack schaefer replied
oh if only i could say that things that
i want to say
how would i describe it this is cheesy
but
it's revealing is what i would say now
keep in mind
this is specifically about episode four
the next episode that we're going to see
in the one division series so this isn't
her saying that it's going to be
revealing
four or five episodes down the road this
is this upcoming friday we're finally
going to be getting some answers she
also confirmed this while speaking with
the rap
she promised that they'll start to
answer some of the many burning
questions that fans have about the
trippy sitcom inspired series
she said we will need to start answering
some questions and clarifying what's
going on
i don't want to spoil it by telling you
how we do it but there are answers to be
had
in the upcoming episodes so there's
going to be a huge reveal in the next
episode and i think episode 4
5 and 6 are all actually going to be
pretty revealing if we think back to
what paul bettany said
about the final three episodes because
remember paul bettany said that one
division is kind of broken off into
three different parts the first three
episodes are the beginning
kind of the introduction where you know
something's wrong but you don't know
what it is
then he said the final three episodes
are when things start to get really
crazy
there's a lot of battles and apparently
there's a battle that has more cgi
than avengers in game had but he didn't
say that much about the middle
so based off of what elizabeth olsen
said and executive producer and head
writer jack shafer said about episode
four being pretty revealing
we can assume that episodes four five
and six
are the big reveals of the series then
after episodes four five and six do the
big reveals that's when the battling
comes in in the last three episodes and
these are going to be huge like i said
paul bettany said they're going to be
absolutely incredible and he said he
works with an actor that he's always
wanted to work with
now we believe this to be the main
villain mephisto or
the grim reaper and mephisto would make
a lot of sense because he
is a demon he's the hell demon basically
satan of the marvel cinematic universe
and marvel universe in the comics so a
lot of spells a lot of hexes a lot of
witchcraft which is also something that
the scarlet witch is going to use as
well so when paul bettany talks about
cgi
the first thing that comes to my mind is
huge hex casting
witch battles wanda will not only use
the powers that we've already seen but
start to use
actual spells and it's most likely going
to be more than just her and mephisto if
billy and tommy
aka wiccan and speed grow up to be full
adults they could join the fight as well
not to mention vision if he's actually
good and the real vision will most
likely take part in the fight as well
and there most likely just isn't one
villain it's most likely not just
mephisto we've already seen an easter
egg for the grim reaper and we believe
agnes is agatha harkness the witch and
we do believe that she is working for
the grim reaper amephisto based off of
the pennant that she wears and she
sometimes wears it as a brooch but in
the last episode she was wearing it
around her neck on a necklace and it
does appear to have the grim reaper on
it which is why we believe that she is a
villain
and we know that hydra is involved in
some way shape or form and the head
writer jack shafer did say that these
are important
commercials that are showing so hydra's
probably going to pop up in there too so
a lot is going to be happening within
the next three episodes as that's when
we're going to get all of these reveals
who is the main villain are there more
than one villain what is agatha
harkness's role
what exactly is this bubble reality and
what do sword
and hydra have to do with all of this
and probably the biggest question
how is vision alive is it the actual
vision that is alive or is it just him
existing in this reality but he's really
dead
expect some big answers next episode
this friday of course i'm doing a watch
party thursday night
and it looks like we're going to finally
get some answers of
what's going on in one division so be
sure to subscribe so you don't miss out
on
any of the latest one division episodes
so you can get the answers of
what exactly is going on let me know
your predictions in the comments down
below don't forget to like the video and
for live updates you can always follow
me on instagram and twitter as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof